oh
okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of uh History of Science and
Technology q a
Let's see we have a number of questions
that got saved up here and
um
let's do there's one from William here
was the invention of computers
inevitable will Evolution always stumble
upon Universal computers given enough
resources what are the implications of
laws of physics and reality
well let's let's talk about the kind of
historical aspect of that so first of
all
the idea
that it's possible to make a universal
computer that is it's possible to have a
fixed set of underlying instructions
that can be knitted together to do any
computation one once
that idea turns out to be surprisingly
ubiquitous among formal systems you
might have thought that in order to make
a computer that would be able to do
arbitrary computations that you would
have to have something with set up
you know using something like the
machine instructions that an actual
microprocessor uses you know things with
registers and arithmetic and this and
that and the other but that is just not
the case it is you know one of the
things that's come out of lots of work
that I've done is this idea of the
principle of computational equivalence
the idea that above some pretty low
threshold
almost any system whose Behavior doesn't
look obviously simple is actually
capable of universal computation that is
that you can take its primitive
components whether it's some simple rule
about black and white cells or whatever
else and by giving appropriate initial
conditions can make it compute anything
you want to compute now it may be
non-trivial to encode the computation to
begin with it may be non-trivial to
decode the results but the stuff that
happens in the middle is can be an
arbitrarily sophisticated computation
and that that is something that can be
done with a whole range of different
kinds of underlying uh Cape underlying
Primitives
so let's talk about the history of kind
of the discovery of that idea it took a
surprisingly long time for that idea to
emerge and be understood
and I would say that
even today the implications of that idea
for for example science and philosophy
and so on are not yet well understood I
mean I myself have been sort of
exploring those ideas for more than 40
years now and uh coming up with things
like computational irreducibility which
I invented in the mid-1980s
um and but the computational
irreducibility has just immense
consequences for the way one thinks
about the world the way one thinks about
you know philosophical questions like
free will the way one thinks about
questions about uh how natural what
natural science really is all those
kinds of things and what the
capabilities of science are has huge
implications but it's something that has
taken a very long time for us to kind of
wrap our heads around and understand
we've certainly been helped by the fact
that there are actual practical
computers in the world and we can get
some experience from seeing how those
work I think that um we have
kind of you know I've developed for
myself lots of intuition about sort of
how the computational universe works by
doing experiments on simple programs and
what they do I mean it's interesting
right now in these times as we see these
large language model AI systems like
chat GPT and so on able to do all the
things they're able to do able to write
essays about almost anything that are
that sound really good even though if
you take them apart they might be
complete nonsense that is again telling
one something it's giving one an
intuition about how to think about
thinking how to think about computation
I don't think I've yet fully
internalized that intuition I mean I
think I in that particular case the
thing that I'm understanding is that
something I've long believed about human
thinking is that it's really based on
sort of patterns and we're sort of
saying well there's this template that
fits this thing fits that thing and so
on and what's happening as we look at
these neural Nets and we have sort of
larger and larger sort of arcs of
training in these neurons of sort of uh
that that what's happening is that we're
getting sort of bigger patterns it's not
just the pattern that says in English
you know cues are mostly followed by use
it becomes a larger pattern and then a
larger pattern a larger pattern and I
think the thing we'll see next is
serious reasoning by analogy which we
haven't yet seen in these systems but I
think it will come because that's again
it's kind of a pattern fits here fits
there and so on and I think that becomes
kind of the story and perhaps that is
the ultimate story of sort of what's the
particularity of human thinking as
compared to arbitrary computation
because we can go out and just sample
the computational universe and find all
kinds of computations that do all kinds
of wild things where we say we have no
human resonance with that computation we
don't know we as humans can see it doing
all those bits of flapping around as
they flap around but we don't have sort
of a human way to understand that and I
think there's some sort of
specialization of human thinking that is
not not the generic arbitrary
computation I mean a lot of my life has
been spent building our full-scale
computational language both from
language which is an attempt to sort of
formalize those parts of the
computational world that we care about
to formalize them in sort of a precise
way but if we want to characterize what
is it about sort of uh the the human
thinking sort of situation that is not
just generic computation and by the way
computation may do things that are very
valuable to us but not in a way that
works like the way human thinking works
so you know there's a question about how
do we characterize that and I think this
idea of these kind of templates and
templates for templates Etc et cetera et
cetera I I've long assumed probably for
40 years have assumed that that's kind
of at some level how human thinking
works and in some sense that's what I've
tried to capture in modern language and
its predecessor uh SMP Back 40 years for
the last 43 years or so of you know
you're making Transformations for
patterns for symbolic Expressions that's
a very formalized version of what I
think is sort of going on in the human
thinking case but we now get to see a
new intuition about that as we can
actually see something that is writing
kind of uh perhaps nonsense and detailed
content but in terms of form sort of
flowing English text
so anyway we've got sort of different
levels of intuition about how uh sort of
how to think about computation
um
another
um
and and so if we look at that
historically the idea that you could
take sort of things we think about and
formalize them so that there are two
kinds of things we can imagine sort of
thinking about in terms of computation
one is thinking and the other is nature
I think the idea of thinking about
nature in terms of computation is
probably an idea that I I guess I'm
probably the one who who really
pioneered that idea in the in the early
1980s and I sort of backed into that
idea but that idea that you can make
kind of program-based models of nature
but you know they're these two cases
anyway thinking about human thinking in
terms of what we would Now call
computation think about nature in terms
of what we would what we talk about as
computation in terms of human thinking
the you know the process of formalizing
human thinking has a long history I mean
you know it the Aristotle you know first
century BC you know logic uh that was a
formalization that was a first level
formalization of human thinking of
saying what's the pattern I mean in a
sense that's sort of the predecessor of
chat GPT is the patterns that
syllogism's made in in logic back in in
uh in Antiquity and then you know we we
go many many many years into the future
and we get to people like George boole
in the 1830s and so on 1840s talking
about uh the sort of laws of thought and
the idea of having sort of a formal uh a
more mathematical kind of way to think
about this process of doing logic
but
you know we skip over there Gottfried
leibniz in the late 1600s who had kind
of this idea of uh uh kind of
formalizing thinking you know his PhD
thesis was about you know how to how to
solve legal cases using logic how to and
he had this idea of a characteristica
universalis a universal language in
which one would convert all kind of um
uh everything that we talk about in
terms of human language into this formal
language and then that formal language
kind of in a very wolf alpha-like style
would turn into something computational
where one could just compute who was
right and who was wrong in this legal
case that was kind of an idea that
leibniz had in the late 1600s there was
a circle of ideas at that time that had
to do with making these sort of
formalized languages so-called
philosophical languages which would sort
of transcend the details of human
language and be something like the thing
I now talk about as symbolic discourse
language
so it's some
you know leibniz I think was pretty
close to the idea of a universal
computer but he didn't quite have it
and in fact it took a long time for the
idea of even an abstract function to
emerge the concept of a function f where
you don't say what it is you know f is
the plus exponentiation whatever else
that was a thing well understood by the
by the 1700s and people at Euler were
using that that idea over and over again
but the idea of an arbitrary function
where you could sort of start talking
about things true for an arbitrary
function that was something that really
came as the formalization of calculus
and so on formalization of mathematics
uh sort of got really uh developed in
the late 1800s now there have been other
sort of previous efforts so for example
Charles Babbage in the 1830s and so on
had been trying to make something which
would be a um an automated generator of
mathematical tables so in this mid 1600s
it was figured out by I think a chap
called chicard was the first person we
know of who did this but Pascal worked
on this and so on to make kind of a a
gear based calculator where you're doing
arithmetic by essentially patterns of
gearing there was a precursor of that in
Antiquity the anticothera device from
around zero A.D or something first
century BC first century ad we don't
really know
um you know we found only one example of
this from this one shipwreck
um off the island of anticothera
um that uh is a kind of a gear based
cog-based in that particular case
astronomical calculator but presumably
many more of those things existed even
Antiquity and so this idea that you can
kind of do arithmetic do computations do
the motion of astronomical bodies in
this sort of gear-based way uh you know
the that motion of astronomical bodies
in a gear-based way sort of reminds one
of the whole epicycles idea of Ptolemy
and so on and that was in a sense the
thing that was being implemented by the
anti-cathera device in a in a simple
case but so this idea that you could
take things that were sort of arithmetic
like and make them mechanical that was
an idea that probably exists in
Antiquity certainly was was known by the
1600s
but then the the thing that Babbage sort
of tried to figure out was okay we we
want to make this machine a big
steam-powered thing the size of the
locomotive that would be something that
would could compute
today it could do a table of logarithms
tomorrow you could have it work out life
insurance tables he wanted something
where you could reprogram it to do these
different things and for that he
developed this idea of Punch Cards Punch
Cards have been developed around 1800 by
Jacquard for doing Loom control for for
um for weaving and so on and um the uh
and the uh and sort of automating taking
a weaving pattern and putting it into
fabric uh but but so Babbage had that
idea and then Ada Lovelace who came
along as sort of an Expositor primarily
a babbage's engineering idea was I think
the one who kind of first got the chance
to figure out yes there's an abstract
thing to talk about here that transcends
the sort of details of the engineering
structure of this particular system and
uh you know she was talking about uh the
analytical engine which Babbage was
named for this this device would weave
algebraical patterns as the Ricard Loom
weaves patterns of flowers and birds
which is kind of a poetic
um
um uh version of of talking about sort
of this idea of arbitrary computation
and she had figured out that you could
sort of compose music with this and you
could do algorithmic music composition
and a bunch of other things so this was
a kind of take things that we normally
do as humans with our sort of processes
of thinking and make them sort of
formalized and computational now this
notion that you could take sort of the
question is this idea of universality
what does it mean to be Universal well
it kind of means you can not just do the
first thing you thought about doing but
you can do all these other things as
well
and I think that is uh
that's the thing where people had a hard
time understanding what's the universe
of things that you would want to be
doing you know that you would want to
cover in a universal system and so
people started thinking about well what
about how do we do math universally you
know David Hilbert
um late 1800s beginning of the 1900s was
very big on let's have a formalized
version of math where we just put down
these Primitives and then all of math is
just mechanically grindable out from
that
and I think the um uh that idea well I
mean there are many twists to the story
about sort of the you know taking logic
and being able to sort of crush down
logic to not use antidote or not but
just use nand
that was something realized around 1900
sort of formalized maybe 1910 by Henry
scheffer and people like that
um that that was a thing and so that
again gave this idea there are simpler
Primitives that you can use that puff
out to bigger things and that led uh
Moses Sean Finkel in 1920 to come up
with combinators combinators are the
first real full example of a what we
would now think of as a computational
universal system and they are they're
things that um
uh the S and K combinators you put them
you kind of construct these symbolic
expressions and you can use them to do
arbitrary computations invented in 1920
still today combinators are super hard
to understand for humans I mean I wrote
a book about combinators a couple of
years ago now and uh that's an attempt
to kind of take into modern times kind
of the idea of combinators and a lot of
interesting things can be said about
them but the fact is they're not very
human compatible they are computation In
The Raw uh powerful but not very human
and I think that that um so that was an
example of the idea of universal
computation it was there in 1920 with
even what Sean Finkel wrote was pretty
clear but it was very hard to really
wrap one's head around what was going on
with with combinators and and it really
took I mean girdle for girdle's theorem
came up with another version of
universal computation General recursive
functions
one of the things that happened was
girdle wasn't sure he could see that
General recursive functions were General
enough to cover arithmetic type
mathematics he didn't know whether they
were really General whether they would
apply to actual human Minds for example
or whether they were just the thing that
was sort of closed within the domain of
mathematics certainly when Turing came
up with Turing machines in 1936 he came
up with them as a way to cover sort of
the mathematical kind of types of
computations that he imagined were the
thing we meant by computation the
question of whether they were broad
enough to cover brains for example well
uh 15 years later he thought about that
a bunch more in sort of early early
talking about Ai and so on but it was
something where it was not self-evident
that uh sort of that kind of computation
the turing machine how how Global it
really was how Universal it actually was
and Turing himself for example didn't
think that Turing machines would cover
physics or biology for that matter and
when he worked on those things he
thought about completely other models
that were much more traditional
mathematical equation-based models I
mean in the end it it sort of fell to me
to kind of take on the idea of well
let's see if we can actually think about
modeling physics I didn't think at the
beginning I didn't think about
fundamental physics other people had
talked about that sometimes in ways that
didn't seem very sensible to me
um but uh you know I kind of got into
the can we take the essence of practical
physics and the modeling we do in
physics and make that kind of
computational so to speak and that did
start working and one did start getting
different intuition from that
but so I think the real question is in
terms of you know how Universal
computation arises and how people
understand what it means and so on I
think it's it's much more in the well
how do we use it and how do we get to
the point where we have been able to see
how it connects with things more so than
the actual uh sort of you know Moses
Jean Franco understood the universal
computation but nobody used what he did
even pretty much to today
um because it was just computation In
The Raw that was very hard to understand
and it was you know the the the
universal computation component
for example in Natural Science I think
it's very important but that's something
that has been completely unobvious until
until quite recently and it's something
where it's kind of like you have to kind
of see it from the science side
um before you kind of can understand it
from the universal computation side so
in terms of sort of the the alternate
histories of of science for instance
let's say the atticathera device had
developed further in Antiquity and
people had gotten to the point that they
understood that you could make a
universal mathematical computation
device in Antiquity I mean I kind of
sometimes have this idea that you know
maybe Archimedes was involved in the
kind of anticothera device construction
there's some evidence for that at least
his sort of school of of things in
Syracuse Sicily was involved with this
but you know I kind of have this idea
what if Archimedes had figured out that
you could make kind of a a thing like
Mathematica so to speak
um back in you know the the whatever you
know third Century Beast oh no he was he
was later than that the first century BC
um second century BC uh
and um you know how would that have
changed the way that we think about
science well the answer is
we might have been discovering calculus
much later we would have had
program-based models of the world and we
would have been executing those models
everybody would have understood
computational irreducibility hundreds of
years ago people would have had a much
different view of what science can
achieve of because people have the view
science exact science is about you write
down the equation and then Kaboom you've
got the answer to everything
this is what computational irreducible
reducibility says doesn't work even
though you might know the rules for a
system there's still sort of this
irreducible computational work to see
its consequences and that's a thing that
um uh is that that would have been
understood hundreds of years earlier
than it than it has been understood it's
still not widely understood as widely
understood as it should be by a long way
so you know I think that's that's a
thing that would have changed now you
know is it the case that well the idea
of using sort of the that nature is full
of universal computers
that's an idea that kind of is you know
something that I introduced and
that idea I mean I can kind of uh
you know could that idea have Arisen
hundreds of years earlier I'm not sure I
think that my ability to introduce that
idea was a consequence of
the fact that I had sort of a some
ambient understanding of computers plus
I had the ability to actually do
computer experiments and I started doing
computer experiments while in the
in the early 70s I did my very first
ones but more seriously in the late at
the end of the 1970s beginning of the
1980s and really that was in terms of
the development of human technology that
was pretty much the first time you could
do those in a serious and and and fluid
kind of way so I I think and that's
probably what led to the realization
that there was this sort of connection
between this this fundamental connection
between ideas of computation and ideas
of Natural Science
but um so that's a very complicated
answer to to uh to the question that was
asked about so the inevitability of
universal computation the phenomenon of
universal computation the principle of
computational equivalence kind of tells
you that's absolutely ubiquitous the
understanding of it and the connection
of it to kind of us humans and the way
we think about things that is much more
a question of the history of ideas now
you know it's an interesting observation
with the current round of neural
networks that that are increasingly
Universal neural networks that are kind
of useful for lots of kind of human-like
tasks
the fact that that is possible is
telling us something the fact that
that's possible is probably telling us
something very deep about the way that
human thinking is kind of carved off
from the general of uh
of kind of what um uh of what happens
with um
um uh the with arbitrary computation
it's telling us that there's this class
of of um of computation that is human
thinking like computation that is
different from General computation
General computation is bigger than human
thinking like computation I mean we we
are fond of thinking that we are the the
coolest things in the universe type
thing but when it comes to sort of our
computational abilities I just don't
think that's true I think and and by the
way a sort of version of this that's
emerged in our physics project is if you
think about General computation and even
multi-computation where you have these
many paths of computational processes
branching and merging and so on when you
think about those things the uh
there's the question of a human Observer
how similar or not are they to arbitrary
computation what we've realized is that
human observers or observers like us
have these two characteristics that are
rather limiting we're computationally
bounded and we believe that we have a
persistent threat of experience and
Through Time
and those things are specializations of
the general computational thing that are
for observers like us and my guess is
that what we're learning from the fact
that these neural Nets can be as
successful as they can on so many
human-like tasks is that we're learning
another sort of universal fact about the
way in which we are limited relative to
the arbitrary computational universe and
you know what that should lead to is a
kind of narrative theory of
thinking and so on that is
you know intermediate between the kind
of the level of the neurons clicking on
and off and the level of sort of
psychology and so on and you know I
think it's an interesting thing that
there's probably there is science to be
taken out of that it's not traditional
mathematical science it's a a different
type of of science that that is again
uh you know I'm not sure quite how to
think about it yet but it's something
where we're getting this idea that human
thinking is this sort of pattern-based
thing and that that really works and
that's patterns upon patterns upon
patterns and kind of meta patterns and
patterns and so on and what one thing
sort of interesting about that in like
wealth language the whole system is
based on Transformations for patterns
and in some sense ones building up
patterns upon patterns there but it
isn't quite the same way that we're
thinking about patterns upon patterns
being built by knowing that so by the
sort of model of thinking that we have
there so anyway it's a it's a um uh it's
a it's a challenge to to understand kind
of what what might a theory that's based
on kind of thinking about thinking in
those kinds of terms be like you know in
the in the history of AI folks like my
friend Marvin Minsky you know were
talking about things like you know how
do we think about thinking I was never
very convinced by the things that Marvin
had to say about that I always thought
that they were uh kind of well they're a
little bit like you know if we take
Freud for example and you know his kind
of view of psychology you know the ego
the super Edo the ID type thing that's a
kind of a narrative story about how
brains work that probably has some legs
but it's not clear it's not clear how
you generalize that it's not clear how
you turn that into a more elaborate
Theory one of the things that's been
great in the history of physics for
example is that it's been possible to do
a great deal of elaboration that is you
have a basic model it allows you to work
out some one particular case like the
pendulum swinging back and forth but
then that same kind of model can be
applied to the the um the triple
pendulum it can be applied to the much
more complicated system Etc et cetera et
cetera there's a kind of elaborative
tower that gets built in a field like
physics and really what what will allow
fields to take off is when there are
similar kind of elaborative towers that
can be built there and so the question
of you know some of Marvin's theories
about AI which I admit that even though
I took him a lot I'm not sure I
understood that well you know theory of
frames or theory of whatever else
um it's it's like so how do you build
something how do you build a tower on
top of that and that's the thing that
one one is able to do that one one's
able to sort of reason about reasoning
in a kind of way well and could build a
tower
that's where I think we start getting
mileage from the kinds of things that
science is really good at the kinds of
things that formal science is good at
which are different from the kinds of
things that we as just everyday human
thinkers are good at
just a few thoughts about that let's see
uh
um
Zayden is comment saying I don't think
that Computing technology was possible
to be conceived until after the
Industrial Revolution
I wonder about that I mean the
anticothera device
is
you know how big a computer do you want
it is difficult to have a cogs-based
computer kind of go the full distance
of Because by the time you have a
computation that can be of arbitrary
length you need arbitrary force on the
first Cog to kind of turn the other cogs
and that's a hard thing to achieve
mechanically and so arguably the you
know one could argue that electronics
and particularly electronic amplifiers
were necessary so that you didn't have
that problem of kind of the the the hard
to turn Cog because once you have
electronic amplifiers you don't you can
just say there's an electronic signal
and oh we're just going to amplify it to
feed it out to all these other things
and and you know that's kind of one of
the key things for digital electronics
is is one can do things like that one
doesn't have to worry about oh the
signal is going to get to to decayed and
it won't be able to drive this other
part it won't be able to last long
enough to do the computation and so on
so there's an argument that one couldn't
have gotten there with mechanical
devices alone but I think one could have
gotten quite a long way
I mean for example it's you know the
logic machines that got built in the
1800s
um the were not very impressive but they
could have been built in Antiquity
somebody perfectly well could have gone
to Plato's Academy and said hey I've got
this thing it's made of the same kind of
metallic object you know construction
materials that the antacothera device
was made of and it does logic and you
know Aristotle might have said wow or he
might have not understood what on Earth
it was or or
um or a variety of possibilities but um
I think
I mean
things that happen in the industrial
revolution
the things like the invention of the
punch card that was an industrial
revolution kind of thing and maybe the
concept
of
kind of
the autonomous doing of things that was
probably an industrial revolution
concept before that time
the sort of Motive Power was something
that came from animals or from the wind
or from something else the concept that
you could make Motive Power from within
the system as like in a steam engine or
something was an industrial revolution
kind of concept I think
and you know it's famously Babbage when
he was um uh talking about some
mathematical tables and had been
involved in some big project to make
mathematical Tables by hand
um uh
was you know had this statement you know
what was it I I Wish by God this could
be done by steam he said in other words
that this process of making mathematical
tables could be automated but his
version of describing that was done by
steam steam was the idea that um uh you
know was um uh
um
uh you know that it was a it was a um
uh it was a that was that was kind of
his metaphor for automation thing is
pointing out that in Antiquity the
knowledge to build a steam engine sort
of existed as well
uh and and commenting that um you know
people were depressingly cheap in those
days and that meant that there wasn't a
motivation to do automation you know I I
um uh
a friend of mine named armandango who's
a Classics professor in in Oxford has
has written about some kind of the the
notion of innovation in Antiquity and um
I think his his main conclusion has been
that um uh one of the areas of an ocean
was in the military area you know if you
made a Siege machine that was better
than the other guy's Siege machine you
were going to win if you made you know
military technology was worth having
because it was it was allowing you to do
things that the other side just couldn't
do you throw enough people into it you
know even if you throw a a lot of people
into it you don't get to scale a you
know a wall a sheer wall uh you know
just with people it just you know there
isn't a way to do that and so that was a
driver I think for some kind of early
technology I think that um uh in
um I do agree that there is plenty that
was not automated in Antiquity because
people were cheap
the same is true today I mean there's a
lot of the production line for you know
your average smartphone that is done by
people because it's still the case that
you know the the that sort of list in
some parts of the world human labor is
cheaper than sort of setting up the
automation the technology to to do it
and human labor is more reliable than
the technology in certain ways and so
even today you know two thousand years
after Antiquity so to speak we're still
in a situation where where you know
we're we're the motivation to do make
robotic factories is not as great as it
might be because human labor is still
cheap enough relative to the amount that
the things that are made in robotic
factories cost and the whole Supply
chains that Supply those robotic
factories and you know where you mine
the metal out of the ground and do this
and do this and do this and do this you
have to you have to kind of cheapen that
whole supply chain before it gets to the
point where you've got to cheapen the
actual final assembly process and things
like that to the point where you don't
have human people in in the loop but I I
think it is it is certainly true that
the motivation to automate comes in part
when human labor gets too expensive to
be used for things
um sometimes the automation happens just
because it can and it's not driven by a
a dire need to avoid the cost of human
labor but sometimes it is
you know I think the um uh the the
question
of you know this is supposed to be about
history of Science and Technology but
let's talk a little bit about the future
too the question of uh you know once we
get to the point where
we can automate almost everything you
know where does that leave us humans
I've said this many times that the you
know the one thing the automation will
never do is to figure out what you want
the automation to do there's still a
spark of kind of what are the goals that
has to come from outside that automated
system but it is an interesting thing to
think about as you automate more and
more and as more and more of the economy
becomes Bots negotiating with Bots Bots
buying things from Bots what does it
look like when the vast majority of
economic activity is bot to bot activity
what does that look like and you know I
had a thought yesterday actually that um
kind of funny that um you know when most
economic activity is in the bot sphere
and where most of it is is you know then
at some level maybe what happens is
everything that is relevant to humans is
free
because it could be the case and I was
thinking what's an analogy well the
answer is to a dog a you know a
domesticated dog its food is free it
doesn't have to do anything to get to it
unless you set it up that way but you
know the it's the the pet food is as far
as the dog is concerned it's free food
it doesn't have to go hunt it
um it's uh uh it's just being delivered
and you know one can imagine a scenario
where there's sort of this bot economy
and that's where the real hard work has
done is by the Bots and the bots of
interacting with this and there's lots
of effort being spent by the Bots and
then in the end sort of the the ultimate
things that are relevant to us humans
are just this tiny little froth on top
of all this bot activity and that
becomes essentially free
just a thought I think that the way to
think about that in well what one way
I've thought about that in the past and
it was a little bit different from that
is you know it is true in the world
today that there are natural resources
where you know there's a mining issue
you know somebody might have a tantal of
mine somewhere and that's very valuable
because you know they have the tantal in
mind the other guys don't have the
tantal in mind
um and the thing that's interesting
about the computational universe is we
all have it and it is minable anywhere
anytime and it's it's just out there as
a formal thing it's you know mining the
rouliad so to speak and that's a thing
that that sort of we can expect to be
done anywhere and I think that's a um uh
that's kind of a that's why in some
sense it might make sense for sort of
everything to become free eventually
because in a sense we have this
inexhaustible source of mining resources
that is the rouliad so to speak and uh
or you know is the pieces of a
computational universe anyway just uh
just a thought there
um
Zayden is commenting ideas alone don't
govern how science evolves It's a
combination of factors including
technology motor production of society
and so on I completely agree I mean my
own life has consisted in this kind of
sort of spiral of upward spiral I'd like
to think rather than downward spiral of
um uh creating science that allows one
to create technology that allows one to
create more science and so on and yes
there is a tremendously tight connection
between the tools that exist and that
are technologically created and the way
that that allows new ideas to be created
then those ideas allow new technology
and tools to be created this has been
both the history of my own trajectory
and the history of kind of the history
of ideas in in much more larger scale
um
memes is commenting the sun's
computation helps sustain us yes
uh
let's see Parker is commenting they like
thinking about machine learning as a
black box that gets to human
comprehendable product but the reasoning
that enables to get to that output is
not understood
um
once we understand what's going on in
machine learning Parker says we can be
confident that it's output is sound yeah
well the problem is we're not going to
understand it the problem is there's a
trade-off if we want to lasso it back
into the understandable we're also
preventing it from kind of Galloping at
full speed
it's that is the nature of computational
irreducibility if you're doing a
computation that is irreducible then you
can't reduce it but in order to
understand it you have to reduce it to
this thing that sort of fits in your
mind and becomes a narrative so it's
kind of a you know you're there's two
opposite forces one is let's go
irreducible and really let computation
achieve everything it can and let's go
understandable where we're pulling it
back into what humans can can wrap their
brains around and that's more limited I
mean as we get sort of and and the way
we get to extend what our brains can do
is through abstraction and the
development of paradigms and the
development of ideas because that that's
how we get to just like we're talking
about sort of this analogical reasoning
type thing of uh of the neural Nets it's
kind of like that's how we get to the
next level up so to speak is we make
this abstraction the that allows us to
to kind of
to not have to go down in the details of
all of that irreducible computation we
get to take a piece of what we're
talking about and make this abstraction
of it that is good enough for what we
care about yes we don't know but precise
details of how those bits move around
but our abstraction is is sufficient to
answer the question we want to answer
and I suppose that's the that's the
issue with this sort of matter model
that I'm talking about for for these
neural Nets is kind of that that meta
model is telling one the parts of sort
of this computational process that are
actually of interest to us as opposed to
all the bit twiddling that's going on
that ultimately isn't something that we
can kind of attach to in a narrative way
so I think it's the case that as soon as
the box is not black the you know the
value of the box has decreased so to
speak
let's see
um puts commented I started playing
chess lately and I noticed that high
level and machine chats is a lot like
proof of computational work and
willingness to commit it do you have
thoughts on that I I don't really have
great intuition about playing chess
um uh and things like that I think that
the I mean when we think about games
it's all a story of sort of game graphs
and you know how do we prune out the
right game graph our right path in the
game graph and that's really the same
story as what we're doing in automated
theorem proven for instance how do we
find that path that gets us to the
theorem how do we find that path through
the game that gets us to The Winning
State those are very much the same kind
of idea uh piece of trivia
um the person who first sort of talked
about game graphs I believe was Ernst
zamello in 1912 who was the person who
was very much involved in set theory and
who was also the person who was involved
in the uh uh reversibility objections to
the second order of thermodynamics
um back in the 1880s
um 1890s perhaps
um
and uh so it's sort of interesting that
that same thread carried through from
kind of thinking about thermodynamics
thinking about those kinds of things to
uh thinking about set theory to thinking
about game graphs and so on
um
yeah so I don't let's see
uh
spare parts is asking I wonder how much
power one would need in order to run a
mechanical computer comparable to a
modern CPU interesting question I know
babbage's analytical engine
was
going to be a big big thing you know
bigger than a locomotive and it was
steam powered it would have been steam
powered and it was able to compute
what was it I think it could do seven
figure arithmetic and it could do oh
gosh I worked this out at some point it
was you know an instruction a second or
something like this so you know a
billion times slower than a modern bill
but maybe its instructions were a bit
bigger but but so give it yeah I'm
roughly a billion times slower than a
modern CPU now to be able to do
computations comparable to a modern CPU
um
with kind of the steampunk type uh
technology
um it's uh uh or Victorian style
technology
um uh
I it's an interesting question I mean my
guess is that you know Babbage I think
had already imagined this kind of very
you know he'd imagine cloud computing so
to speak you know if you want a back
project from today's world you imagine
cloud computing and he imagined that you
would have uh kind of these these
engines these stations where you would
do you know big computations and you
would build a few of them and a life
insurance company would come in and
compute it it's uh it's Insurance tables
and um uh the navigation people would
come in and compute their thing it's
very much like the super computer story
or the cloud story today and you know
there was a branch of History where Ada
Lovelace would have been the CEO of that
operation and we would have had the
first software company back in the 1840s
you know ceoed by Ada Lovelace with
Charles Babbage or CTO so to speak and
that almost happened but it didn't quite
for reasons of uh you know Ada Lovelace
got cancer and uh you know Charles
Babbage never really internalized that
Vision properly and and never convinced
the British government to
um uh uh to fund the thing in a more
serious way and um and you know it
didn't happen that that history never
happened but it was fairly close to
happening I think
um
let's see
spare parts is asking do I think that
modern AI systems are unique in terms of
replacing human work or just another
step in automation I think they're just
another step in automation
and you know I was thinking today with
with uh you know the chat GPT stuff and
so on you know which can now write a
very high quality essay that is can be
complete nonsense
I was asking it something about
um uh write a persuasive essay that
wolves are The Bluest of all animals
and it it started talking about the blue
wolf paren canis something or other that
lives in the Tibetan plateau and that
gets its its color through structural
coloration that is the same thing that
butterflies use and so on it's complete
nonsense I mean it really had me a
little bit fooled there it was like
really is there a blue wolf I you know I
never heard of a blue wolf are there
wolves in the Tibetan Plateau I don't
know uh you know and it was it was very
convincing and it is a you know it's an
interesting question what what happens
to the world now that it's possible to
write absolutely you know on on their
face convincing kinds of arguments and
essays and no doubt marketing pictures
and all this kind of thing completely
automatically
um
what I was thinking what is the thing
that will really change so back when I
was a kid
once handwriting method
you know you would get you'd write an
essay and uh you know it's like part of
the the grade if one cared about that
was you know could anybody read one's
handwriting and um and then handwriting
just sort of went away for most purposes
you know people type everything
and then there was a time when you could
kind of tell a little bit about people
by their spelling you know it's like oh
this is a well-educated person they know
how to spell and or at least they're you
know if they if they uh dyslexic or
something they're using a dictionary
they're going to the trouble of using
addiction whatever it is okay the um and
then that went away because there are
spell Checkers and now if I get
something where words are misspelled
it's like just this person was kind of
kind of dumb to do this because you know
why didn't they why didn't they switch
on the spell checker and so you know one
of the things that I think will be a
consequence now for example is there
won't be any excuse to to write broken
English
even if you started off with broken
English you'll be able to run it through
uh you know through one of these systems
and it will smooth the text so it will
sound just fine just as it can smooth
the text with language translation it
can smooth the text there so that's an
example of automation
but you know if we look at the bigger
picture of what jobs get automated what
do not I did a bit of a study which I
never wrote up unfortunately I I
talked about it once or twice but um I
was actually a bit frustrating because I
looked at the data from the uh Bureau of
Labor Statistics and its predecessors
all the way back to um to like the late
1700s in the US of oh it's a Census
Bureau data actually Census Bureau data
sorry
um asking what were the occupations in
the U.S
and you know back in the in the
beginning of the 1800s the vast majority
were agricultural occupations and what I
tried to do was to bucket occupations
because the the actual details of the
occupations have changed over time you
know for example I don't know what was
the term like a a chain man or something
is not an occupation today it's somebody
I think who was who helped surveyors
with with their activities or a tinker
is not really an operation an occupation
today
um or a cobbler you know making and
those were occupations that were listed
in the list of occupations so I tried to
bucket these things to get sort of what
the overall flow of occupations had been
and and you know what you observed was
um
uh some things you know that the general
decrease of Agriculture the increase of
of everything to do with government
Municipal Services of various kinds the
increase of Health Care the increase of
uh education as occupational areas
um the uh the sort of uh military you
know went a bit up and down but not not
so much
um manufacturing actually not as much
decrease as one might have thought in
terms of people uh you know just a lot
of detailed things and I was trying to
conclude from this was probably nearly
10 years ago now I was trying to kind of
conclude what can we learn about kind of
the ebb and flow of human activities and
you know when automation comes in what
does it really do and you know how does
all those clerks who were
um
you know doing adding up numbers and and
keeping you know
um filing clerks for example
um you know the number of filing clerks
has dramatically decreased because now
we're using online databases for that
and uh you know that that that thing got
automated away
but what has continually happened is
that you know new things open up new
occupations open up and who knew that
you could be a professional video gamer
who knew that you could be a uh uh you
know a linguistic curator who knew that
you could be an AI psychologist you know
these are all new you know who knew that
you could be a prompt engineer
um for you know uh for for figuring out
you know how to create the prompts for
for you know some some creativity system
of some AI system and so on so there
there are these new things or who knew
you could be a uh uh an online community
moderator these are all professions that
grew up uh as a result of Technology but
it's uh it's something that you know
hadn't existed before now if you look at
the places where humans are still very
much in the loop there's a lot of what
one might call persuasion professions
where humans are in the loop whether
that's sale skills teaching uh
I don't know Psychiatry I don't know you
know places where
the human customer in a sense
uh
needs to be persuaded by there being a
human there
and you know partly that's sort of the
commitment of oh you know somebody a
person is flying This Plane it's not you
know there's commitment on the part of
the person who's flying the plane that
they're going to try and bring it into a
safe landing so to speak rather than
just oh that's just a machine doing it
and um you know we're we're relying on
the legal system that somebody has
liability if you crash the plane and
kill all the people on it
um it's uh you know that there are these
places where the human and the loop is
necessary for sort of the commitment of
there really is a human who's putting
effort into this
um and you know you see this in business
quite often where there's a kind of you
know well are you actually going to do
the meeting take the meeting you know is
is this level of poo bar in this
organization going to take the meeting
you know that level the commitment is a
large part of kind of what's going on
and it's kind of necessary to have that
slice of kind of human human commitment
that's that's the story and if you say
oh let's just put a machine in place
there the human commitment is removed
the human persuasive component is
removed and that profession just doesn't
work so I think there are there are
professions like that that were human in
the loop if your customer is human
you're kind of that's that's the thing
now there are other places where there
are uh you know and I suppose the same
is true in um
uh
you know in in a um
there are settings you know we see this
with um uh things like uh you know music
might be free but the um uh you know the
concerts that are these experiential
events that involve sort of human
commitment of people being there and so
on are are you know part of the the big
part of the commercial story you know I
I think this notion of
um
sort of humans are there just for the
sake of humans being there is is a thing
that isn't going to get automated away
just as the kind of high level so what
do we want to do isn't going to get
automated away although there is an
argument that leadership is always a
small fraction of total activity and if
all you were left with was kind of
everybody disappeared except the upper
management and it was just upper
management kind of um uh telling you
know AIS what to do all the way down
that it is the case that a huge number
of occupations are not you know the top
leadership so to speak they're making
everything work uh down below that so to
speak and if you could automate that
away there will be many fewer slots for
those kinds of things you know so I
think um uh it's some
um
uh yeah so so you know is is a really
interesting question what uh sort of
where does the where do the humans fit
in I mean there was probably a Time
when
people said look as soon as there are
bulldozers it's all over for humans you
know don't you know that having that
whole team of humans to you know pick up
the tree trunk and move it from here to
there you know that's what we humans are
able to do I mean you know if we were
building the pyramids today I don't know
how many people the millions of people
involved in building the pyramids uh you
know if the pyramids were being built
today the crew that built the pyramids
would be incredibly much smaller than
the crew that actually built the
pyramids back in the day and you know
because there is automation there are
you know big machines and so on and I
think you know people might have thought
thinking about that future oh my gosh
it's all over for the humans uh you know
it's just going to be machines all the
way down but yet there's still you know
eight billion humans or whatever uh who
mostly feel like they're doing something
that is necessary for them to do they
can't just sit back relax and let the
AIS do everything that needs to be done
that's that's not happened and my guess
is that it's going to continue to be the
case that there's a sort of evolution of
these niches that humans for whatever
reason including the kind of uh sort of
persuasion commitment professions you
know end up needing a human to be in
those loops
Aaron is commenting that he may change
his email signature written by chat GPT
please excuse any nonsense that's an
amusing idea
um you know
I long ago put something on you know for
email that I send from voice to text
systems that um basically says dictated
whatever
um you know to avoid the fact that
sometimes the words will just be Bonkers
there
um but uh you know it is an interesting
question you know I get a lot of mail
and
from you know I make uh many people
think I'm crazy to do this but I make a
a real effort to try and do something
when I whenever I have anything sensible
to say with with mail that I get or my
team gets and um you know the thing I
realized is oh my gosh the stuff I get
that you know could I tell you
immediately that it was you know an llm
you know large language model piece of
mail or was it real mail I couldn't tell
you know it's the same thing as when you
know I have heuristics for telling am I
getting fished
um and uh
um the um
uh and those heuristics I guess you know
I don't know how well those heuristics
are going to work on sort of certain
kinds of mail that one gets uh that can
be generated now automatically and it's
it's it's interesting I mean it's an
interesting Dynamic of what will be the
the um uh you know probably fishing has
caught pH fishing has caused people to
read their mail a little bit more
carefully uh maybe this will do the same
kind of thing I'm not sure
um
let's see
uh
huh
let's see
uh crypto is commenting it's temp it's
tempting to think the general AI will
have a sort of digital version of
evolution
um look there's digital Evolution all
over the place I mean there's evolution
in products
um there's the you know the automation
of evolution as certainly there are many
places where that's been done and at
where it has I mean you know a lot of
even the training of chat GPT I think
had some sort of natural selection that
was being done by actual humans saying
that's a good story that's a bad story
and so on
um and uh I think you know this is a um
uh digital evolution is well underway
um and how autonomous it will be you
know the the invisible hand so to speak
uh you know it can be and how visible
the hand will be is not clear what the
best way to do that is is not clear but
there's definitely some sort of
evolutionary process on the way
um
and talking about which I need to
go and uh
there's some other things in a moment
but there was a question here from Ollie
asking historically how has written
record keeping evolved will we ever
revert to oral records and so on
well you know written records were a
thing of the creation of cities in in
the Babylonian times that's when people
started wanting to record things in a
sort of more permanent way that's when I
suppose you were dealing with you know
before that it was like oh yeah I know
so and so and so and so and I remember
they you know gave me a a pot of you
know a pot of Honey or something and I I
owe them or whatever and we can just
remember that and it's a small kind of
uh small group of you know I don't know
50 people or something and everybody
sort of remembers what was happening and
then by the time there were cities much
larger aggregations of people became
more important to have records which
were sort of more plug compatible
between different groups and so on and
that's that's kind of how the whole
process of uh writing and recording
things and so on uh kind of got started
and the process of having
um
sort of how much one records I mean I
myself have been a a personal analytics
nut so to speak and I probably recorded
more stuff about myself over the last 30
years or so than pretty much anybody
else has and you know down to what
keystrokes I type and all the emails I
send and all the all the things that I
you know the documents I produce in
every intermediate stage and so on so
and so on
um it's uh one is recording all that
stuff exactly what one does with it is
unclear and you know it's rare that I
pull it out and and do things with it
um but I think uh
I did realize one thing which is by the
time
okay so you know
shocking fact of the day if you feed
typical you know College admission type
prompts into chat GPT and ask it to
write essays it does a reasonable job
it does a shockingly good job actually
um including just making up stories that
are just complete nonsense about how you
know it tried out for a football team
and things like this
and you know that was in in response to
some prompt about you know tell us about
a place where you failed and learned
from your failure or some such other
thing and it makes up these stories and
they're just Absolute Total nonsense
um but they seem very convincing and you
know if you ask it to do things like um
oh I asked it to write some
thing about
um uh write a sad story about this or
that and it wrote a very you know quite
a convinced thing quite a um uh you know
a a sort of structurally uh kind of
convincing version of that and um
let's see where was I going with this I
I was talking about yeah the the um uh
written records and so on so I realized
that um
uh
you know
a lot of when people are
trying to you know hire people do
uh you know pull people into education
type things I've always believed that
you really kind of have to do interviews
if you actually want to find out you
know who makes sense and who doesn't for
some particular in some particular
situation
but an awful lot of people think oh you
don't have to do that you just get
people to write essays and so on I think
they just get people the right essays
thing just got exploded and the kind of
interactive
uh kind of um interview thing is likely
to be the more uh you know the more
convincing thing and uh you know perhaps
even the things I try to do with these
with these live streams where I'm just
you know taking questions I don't know
are coming and trying to kind of uh sit
and talk about them uh you know that may
be one of the things that one sort of
retreats to uh away from the kind of the
uh the kind of just write an essay
because it's like an essay can be
generated automatically but if you
really want to check there's a human in
the loop you know you ask them a
question you have them respond in real
time now in time they'll be you know
video avatars of humans and things like
this which will get better and better
and pretty soon you know and I I
certainly have every intention of
training a bot on myself so to speak and
you know I've got enough one of the
advantages of having recorded so much
about my life life because I have a huge
amount of Bot training data and that uh
you know so it may be quite shocking
that at some point I'll be able to
produce a bot that can answer questions
like these in a way that is a first
approximation to the way I would do it I
like to think that there's sort of
bigger arcs of putting things together
that that will not be achievable by
something sort of pretty much other than
me but that becomes kind of the the
human signature then is do you have all
the memories so to speak and all of the
the sort of connections that can be made
um
yeah well uh Sergio comments the GPT 4
and gpt5 are going to be amazing
undoubtedly they will you know that's
the question of what does that
technology curve really look like
because you know I've seen in my life a
huge number of Technology curves that
have a rapid growth period and then they
level off and eventually everything all
of these technology curves level off I
mean you know steam engines were a big
thing in the you know whatever beginning
of the 1800s and so on and they had a
very rapid growth rate and you know
every month somebody was putting out a
new kind of steam engine and it was it
was big but then you know steam engines
plateaued and the question is and a lot
of kinds of Technology you know they
achieve a certain thing they end up
being spectacular for that thing people
find use cases for that thing and then
everybody says that's amazing
and uh you know that's really the issue
you get a certain thing you get this
blob of technology and then you ask
yourself it achieves these things what
are its use cases and that then can that
blob itself expand to be you know to do
more things or is it more a story of
finding use cases
and
it's unclear to
me I mean I know that you know networks
that do classification things like that
for image processing things of this kind
you know we did a bunch of things with
that back in 2016 2017 things like that
uh maybe it was even earlier than that
um no it was 2014 even I'm not sure
um and yeah you could get a certain
distance and that that allowed one to do
a bunch of things and they're pretty
cool and they have interesting use cases
but that in and of itself isn't like the
thing that's driving uh what happens
next so I I don't really know at what
point you know
you know did we just reach the threshold
so for example with language translation
we got there pretty much pretty much
language translation is now doable a
human language translation and you know
there will be improvements but that
hurdle got got crossed as did a bunch of
other kinds of things so it's unclear to
me exactly what's the what the growth
curve looks like and and one shouldn't
make the assumption that just because
it's growing rapidly now means it will
always grow rapidly I mean that's the
that's the that's the famous mistake in
you know uh Market in in financial
trading and so on where you say it's
going up now it's going to keep on going
up forever you know look it's been going
up for the last two months that means
it's going to go up forever well no it
doesn't
um but predicting when the end is is
very hard
and uh you know where's the peak
um
uh
okay that's a good question prototype
asks
uh while I'm talking about interviews
and so on
will the interviewer care if the
candidate is an AI that's a really good
question if you do an interview and the
interviewee is just amazing at being
able to respond for the things they need
to do to do the job and it turns out the
interview is an AI yeah it's a good
point you might say let's just hire them
now
you know that creates this very
interesting Dynamic let's hire the AI
you know
what if the AI was a a bot
it becomes very weird I mean the labor
market then becomes very weird because
the the bot might be free and the bot
might have no economic it all gets very
strange but yes that's it that's a cute
point
um
OG ask has chat GPT passed the Turing
test can it pass the test soon I think
it has effectively passed the Turing
test
um I mean I'm sure there are details
where you can tangle it up and you can
do this and that and the other but I
think for most people uh you know as a
practical matter yeah we pretty much got
there for that particular version you
know if you say
um
did it so so now we we have here's an
interesting version of the Turing test
could it pass for Alan Turing
interesting question I don't know
we don't have a single recording man
touring but we know
um uh you know would it um
um the uh uh that's a question would it
pass for
your average Middle School student yes
is my view would it pass for uh you know
the the kind of the finest humans we
have at making sort of big thematic
conclusions no it will not yes
um but uh yeah it's an it's an
interesting moment I suppose
um prototype is saying suspect the major
deployment of AI in short term will be
phishing
um
uh oh that's an interesting point for
the time being can't replace regular
employees a legitimate businesses
because it can't be held legally
response culpable for because it's not
conscious oh that's such a philosophical
mess but for scammers that's not
impediment good point good point I mean
this is the same thing this is the story
of all these use cases and a lot of use
cases for machine learning you know
machine learning is like 80 successful
20 disastrous but there are use cases
where 80 success is enough classic
examples are feeds for social media or
search engine results if 8 out of 10
results on the first page are what you
want everybody's a winner to a
completely nuts you don't care
but on the other hand there are other
use cases where if 20 of it is Bonkers
it's disastrous so you know there are
these different use cases that you have
to think about and that's you know
that's kind of the the way that that um
uh
that works now in terms of legal
responsibility
uh
you know
I think that's a very complicated issue
because
it is clear that there are automated
systems that do things which kind of
extend the reach of the human you know
you could say where
when you crash your car you could say I
didn't do it it was the cruise control
that did it or whatever or the
self-driving feature that did it
but I think
you know the theory of liability tends
to be the case that you know
it's looking back to was there a human
in the chain so to speak
and I suppose
yeah I mean it's an interesting question
what
um
you know whether the human in the chain
ends up eventually being the builder of
the AI system fortunately that didn't
really happen with software it could
have been the case that you know the
software industry was kind of killed by
people saying oh
you know it was the software that made
me do that and then the software maker
would be liable for all the things that
happened as a result of of somebody
doing that so you know and that that
didn't happen in that in that domain and
yeah it's a well okay there's a
different topic for another time perhaps
about sort of the the ethics of AIS and
um uh responsibility and so on and and
the notion of Consciousness and what
what it takes to have for a thing to
have sort of a notion of responsibility
and so on
all right well I should wrap up there
but um thanks for a lot of interesting
questions and comments and um uh you
know
as you probably
on these topics that are really uh
um
whatever they call it you know an
unfolding story so to speak I mean I've
been actively thinking about some of
these questions about sort of the the
modern stage of AI and so on
um and uh
so as I talk about this you know and
successive uh live streams and weeks and
so on uh no doubt my position will
change somewhat as I understand more but
I I've appreciated
um uh even today I think I've probably
from the beginning of this discussion to
the end I made a little bit of progress
in understanding uh you know how I how I
at least think about uh what's going on
in these areas and um it's something
that uh I think there's a there's a few
more kind of cognitive jumps to be made
and um I uh uh yes I have had some fun
sort of asking chat GPT about some of
those things and uh you know it's it's
interesting to see the extent to which
it's like oh yeah okay that's a Thing
Worth thinking about with it's kind of
jogs me into thinking about that
particular kind of thing
anyway well thanks for joining me here
and um
see you uh
another time I'm not quite sure which
day I'm doing one of these again I I'm
just a I I'm kind of like one of these
humans who is uh uh like the humans
where the AIS are in charge I'm just I
just look at my calendar and uh follow
what it says to do because some some
overall system was built in the past
that causes it to to have that structure
and I'm just following through on it all
right well thanks for joining me and see
you another time bye for now